all social pressure incentivizes people  to claim oppression and victimhood and  to deny their own privileges this  creates ever multiplying victim groups  false victim groups like these people  this creates ever multiplying racial  victims i know you're so oppressed my  dears i know life is so hard for you you  have to live in the richest most  equitable most just country in the  history of the world you have to get a  college education you have to  voluntarily go to lectures it's so awful  i can't imagine that you know the people  people who are in war-torn nations they  must truly  they must truly fit you goodbye goodbye  then  i didn't think i was this intimidating  i believe that gentleman just threw  paint on  [Music]  that's what happens when you assault  people by the way folks